bilal franchement des très heureux de te
voir et le livre mobile al hassani
singulier tu parles de beaucoup beaucoup
de choses notamment à l'école tu dis que
c'était très dur pour toi tu avant
d'arrêter les colons à quel âge j'ai
fait mon bac
il avait fait un deal avec ma maman
quand j'avais 8 ans on était en train de
manger du poisson et je vais dit maman
moi je vais être chanteur je veux pas
aller à l'école c'est nul les maths
elle m'a dit tu vas t'entraîner d'abord
et tu passe ton bac et par tout le monde
et à ton bac tu fais ce que tu veux
c'est ça et donc on a une fin j'ai tenu
cette promesse j'ai eu un bac l
non littéraires aujourd'hui bien sûr et
persanes singulier lagarde et michard et
entendu les lettres de mon moulin a
entendu tout ça bien sûr j'en passe et
des meilleurs la mise de maupassant
j'ai arrêté l'école à
j'ai fait trois quatre mois de
l'université après ça va sauver sa tasse
ou lundi tu dis à l'école c'est toi qui
le dit dans le livre tu dis où te
reprocher de rouler du cul ouais je
voulais pas du cuse était déjà en fait
j'avais sept ans à ce moment là je ne
sais même pas ce que je fais ma démarche
naturelle et il trouvait que je marchais
comme une fille et j'ai a eu cet épisode
un peu traumatisant pour moi que je
raconte dans le livre j'étais à la
piscine municipale avec ma maman
ok tu es loin en train de faire sa vie
et mon frère dans la piscine moi j'avais
peur de l'eau donc je n'avais pas et je
voulais aller aux toilettes et à mes
camarades de classe qui m'ont vu et ils
ont commencé à se [ __ ] de moi mais
arrivent très très peur et j'étais un
peu tout ça dans mon truc je suis devenu
tout rouge et donc c'est là que j'ai
commencé vraiment à à camoufler un petit
peu là les craintes que j'avais le raid
que j'étais triste parce que je pensais
qu'être triste c'était mauvais donc je
garder la tête haute et j'avançais comme
ça malgré le fait qu'ils étaient en
train de m'insulter c'est là que j'ai
commencé un petit peu à apprendre c'est
certain tony sipp étirements de
confiance et serrer la vis là tu te
livre vachement dedans tu parle même de
ta première fois j'avais pas envie de
parler de ma première fois juste pour
parler de ma première fois c'était pas
ce n'était pas le but mais c'était
vraiment les quais c'est pour toutes les
personnes qui vont quitter sa fille je
pense voilà je parle est un petit peu là
parce que moi j'étais un jeune garçon
qui commençait à découvrir sa sexualité
au collège et quand on est homosexuel
dans un dans un bahut où on est le seul
homosexuel c'est un petit peu on n'a pas
de relation il ya pas les petites
amourettes d'école on se tient la main
et on se fait le bisou sur la joue et
c'est moi j'avais pas le droit à ça
et donc ça arrive à beaucoup de jeunes
qui sont dans mon cas est qui et qui
sont pas hétéro il voit d'un seul coup
confronté à l'aspect plus vulgaire en
fête de l'amour et à ce côté très sexuel
et fournira les allergies étonnante
c'est que c'était avec un garçon qui est
avec qui et avec une fiancée qui était
avec un garçon qui était qui et c'est un
garçon qui était avec quelqu'un qui
était quoi éclairer avec une jeune fille
qui était de mon ami je suis désolé
qu'ils étaient tour qui était ton ami
oui et il paraît que voilà il s'est dit
voilà quel âge il a 13 ans je crois au
présent 13 ans et demi mais il paraît
que j'avais une aventure ensemble et
après il y retourner avec avec salah et
saha csu et ça a créé des grosses
complications dans mon établissement
malgré le fait que c'était juste une
rumeur
mais ce n'était pas vrai mais voilà
après en fait non mais c'était vrai mais
en gros pour répondre le corps bas par à
part lui et moi j'ai servi dirais donc
tout le monde en parlait et saab au
congrès nsa a fait que après mais il me
dit partir du nom j'ai dû quitter
l'établissement et pas lui juste moi et
donc c'était un peu compliqué après
voilà c'était à 13 ans j'étais très très
jeune j'ai beaucoup de regrets par
rapport à ça dans ma tête je ne dirai
jamais que j'allais en parler
publiquement
et si jamais on ne désire c'est parce
que vraiment ce n'était pas quelque
chose que j'avais envie de faire et j'ai
été un petit peu mis dedans et c'était
c'était dur en fait à vivre mais sur le
moment je me rendais pas compte et avec
du recul je me rends compte que c'est
être autant fait célibataire oui mais ce
schéma denis fine on ne doit pas être
évident pardon la dette s'ils battent
airs de ville même une sexualité
j'imagine quand on est aujourd'hui
connue comme toi femme bien sûr après
voilà moi je fais je fais attention à
mes relations je vais je suis un peu
devenu une mémé moi je sors pas être
tout juste une petite genre voilà j'ai
très bien avec ouais moi j'ai énormément
aimé ce livre est vraiment il faut il
faut préciser que vous l'avez écrit
aussi avec delphine saubaber grain très
grande journaliste et ça m'a ému mais
vous pouvez pas savoir quand et à sa
mère lui demande s'il a eu ce qui s'est
passé le seul garçon il dit bah oui j'ai
voyagé il s'est passé quelque chose sa
mère lui dit vous êtes embrasser oui
vous avez eu un rapport sexuel
oui tu t'es protéger oui fait la
vaisselle mais il ya aussi une vidéo
moins joyeuse que je vais te montrer
d'accord parce que je trouve que ça a
été très très cool tu n'as pas de faire
cette vidéo c'est dans laquelle tu avec
ta maman tu réponds commentaires que tu
reçois de haters
il y en a des très très trash on a gardé
on en a gardé un des moins violent parce
que voulait pas mourir et le scav est ce
qu'il y en avait des traits très violent
et si ta mère répond poliment au début
on sent que fur et à mesure elle monte
un peu en pression j'adore ta maman
c'est un amour chaque fois il vient
d'accompagner je l'adoré
magnifique en plus et c'est vrai que je
trouve que ça le faire avec sa maman et
répondent waters s'est elle trouve une
vidéo mêle incroyable tu as beau regarde
je te remettre dans le droit chemin
aller à la paix que dieu nous protège
rien ne va plus j'aimerais bien savoir
si dieu lui a dit directement que
monfils bilhac du a créé n'était pas sur
le droit chemin
j'aimerais bien savoir si dieu lui a dit
directement ce que c'était que le droit
chemin
donc miser beautiful ta gueule elle
démarre et un moment sa mère elle nous
fait nous une sorte une très nette
elle démarre bien c'est sympathique
comme ça et après tu sais quelle réponse
une fois sur le plan intellectuel
argument est ensuite telle restriction
du choix compris par le type aurait un
dessin a compris la première elle répond
alors tu dis c'est mon histoire c'est
celle d'un enfant humilié devenu roi je
suis né en banlieue parisienne j'ai 19
ans je suis gay et mon rêve absolu a
toujours été de devenir une pop star est
ce qu'aujourd'hui pour toi tu à réaliser
ton rêve mais je pense que oui
personnellement moi ma perception de mon
rêve elle est complètement réalisé
maintenant l'avis de certains
divergent un peu il y en a qui disent
que je suis là pour un bon petit ans et
qu'après je fais disparaître il y en a
plein qui disait le lendemain de
l'eurovision va plus jamais le voir je
suis là
voilà c'est tout moi j'écris des j'écris
ma musique je compose ma musique je
coproduis mes morceaux je suis à la
direction artistique de mes clips de ma
tournée co chorégraphe costil is je
travaille très très dur sur ce que je
fais artistiquement et le fait que j'ai
l'occasion de le faire j'ai beaucoup de
chance de le faire et ça s'est réalisé
mon rêve je remplis un olympia georges
une semaine et ça c'est un truc vraiment
complètement fou et c'est déjà bien
quatre ans on devient vite agathe oui
oui non parce que j'ai lu le livre et je
pense qu'il est parce que tu es
extrêmement suivie par les jeunes oui il
est très jeune même et je pense que le
fait de le lire quand quelle que soit
notre sexualité d'ailleurs peut les
aider à s'assumer
est ce que tu racontes et le livre est
souvent présenté comme ça c'est
l'histoire d'un garçon un jeune garçon
humilié etc
mais c'est aussi l'histoire d'un garçon
extrêmement fort parce que très jeune tu
à conscientiser ce que tu provoqué chez
les jours tu vas conscientiser qui tu
étais est a tout fait pour assumer
toujours pleinement et ça c'est un
exemple incroyable aujourd'hui c'était
vraiment sale intérêts le but du livre
c'était vraiment de parler à ma
communauté de fans qui sont des jeunes
qui sont des fois au collège au lycée
qui traversent des épisodes comme les
miens et je veux leur montrer voilà
regarder ce que j'ai traversé
aujourd'hui je vais bien aujourd'hui je
sens très fort dans ta tête de rêve
c'est grâce c'est grâce à ces épisodes
un petit peu dur et ce quand on les vit
on a l'impression que c'est la fin du
monde qu'on a on ne peut plus vivre
qu'on peut plus avancer moi je veux leur
dire voilà vous pouvez avancer et
quelques années tu étais ce qu'on
appelle un directionnel c'est-à-dire un
fan du groupe one direction
oui rappel ou pas je me souviens très
bien j'avais mes posters dans toute la
chambre et je pleurais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et je boirai les one direction et je me
rappelle isabelle était fan de l'europe
qui avait créé un groupe gps
[Musique]
les 13 ans en 2013 il y avait l'avant
première du film des moines qui régule à
paris si aller on a retrouvé des images
août avait été interviewé par non-stop
people non mais je me garde des traîtres
ils étaient comme house
si je peu déçu mais bon
parce qu'ils voient l'avant première de
tous les pays bas là non mais bon c'est
pas grave
[Applaudissements]
pour aller voir que l'avant-première
étaient qu'à leurs 19 heures et j'ai pas
chanter dans la queue pour rien et je
criais je pleurais toute la journée
d'étude est gravé l'été commence